INTERVIEWER: Hi.
I'm here today with
Rob Sheffield.
Rob is a music critic,
an author.
He's written three books at
this point, "Love is a Mix
Tape," "Talking With Girls About
Duran Duran," and "Turn
Around Bright Eyes," which
just was issued.
ROB SHEFFIELD: Yeah.
INTERVIEWER: Ostensibly, the
book's about karaoke.
But it also kind of looks at how
and why we love and how we
kind of process and absorb loss,
and specifically the
loss of your wife.
And as well, it also kind of
looks at how we rebuild.
And it tracks the blossoming of
your relationship with your
current wife.
And it does all this through
the lens of karaoke.
ROB SHEFFIELD: Karaoke explains
everything in my worldview.
INTERVIEWER: So for most of us,
karaoke is something we do
maybe after a few
drinks at a bar.
And it's fun, but that's kind
of the significance it has.
But obviously, it plays a
greater role in your life.
And you use the book
to track that.
But how could you sum that up
for the audience here, in
terms of the importance
of karaoke?
ROB SHEFFIELD: Karaoke, it's a
beautiful thing because it
lets anybody participate in
music, even those of us with
no skill whatsoever.
Are there actual
musicians here?
Musicians?
Someone?
All right.
Some musical talent is
represented in the room.
That is not where I come in.
I have none at all.
Always wanted to sing.
Always dreamed of it.
Always been someone
who loves music.
Grew up obsessive about it.
My parents, they were like '50s
rock and rollers, and I
grew up in the '70s, '80s.
I was always obsessed with
music, and yet all my attempts
to sing or play an instrument
were just disastrous because I
just do not have that thing
that is required.
I still have a guitar next to
my desk that I've had there
for 20 years that I always
think, this is going to be the
year that I learn
to play guitar.
I'm going to finally
learn some chords.
The closest I ever got was the
summer of '86, I learned the
chords to "Wild Thing." And I
made a tape because I knew
that it was going to wear
off after a few hours.
And I still have this tape
of me playing "Wild
Thing" for 20 minutes.
And even the chord changes, so
it's like [HUMMING], and I
never got any better
than that.
That was my peak
as a musician.
I'm glad I documented it.
So karaoke actually
allows me to
participate in making music.
As far as I'm concerned,
miraculous.
Greatest thing ever.
INTERVIEWER: I was trying to
track whether you were talking
about the old-school "Wild
Thing" or the Tone Loc one.
ROB SHEFFIELD: Yes.
That one I can rap.
That one's a lot easier.
But it's fun because karaoke
is something that, once it
arrived in this country,
people started
to realize it existed.
And people instantly
wanted more of it.
It's amazing how fast it spread,
and that 20 years ago,
it was pretty much unknown
in the US.
But that it's just this amazing
way of sharing music
and way of participating in
music that lets anybody in.
All the barbarians
at the musical
gates are welcome inside.
INTERVIEWER: And this book, as
well as your first one, is
almost structured like a mix
tape, where you use certain
songs as points of departure.
How do you pick these songs?
ROB SHEFFIELD: I guess for the
things that I wanted to write
about, sometimes the songs
suggested themselves.
Like I have a chapter
about my dad.
And my dad really likes
to sing Elvis songs.
And my dad, his voice is every
bit as bad as mine.
And as a little kid, hearing
my dad sing along with the
radio, I always thought, wow.
I hope I inherit all the awesome
things about my dad,
but not the voice.
Yeah, yeah.
That, of course, I got, as well
as, fortunately, many of
his other wonderful qualities.
But so that chapter, the song
that set me off, and the song
I listened to while
writing it, was
"Heartbreak Hotel," by Elvis.
Because that song has like
three notes in it.
My dad can't even do that one.
[SINGING]
Since my baby left me, I found
a new place to dwell.
And it's not a hard
song to sing.
That's why it was the song that
Bill Clinton played on
saxophone on "The Arsenio Hall
Show." Super easy song.
But for me, I don't really
talk about Elvis
or the song so much.
Just that song is a way into
the topic of my dad and my
life as his son.
Because all the different sort
of emotional relationships in
my life, because for me, music
is just the way that I
translate all the other
aspects of my life.
So read about all these
different relationships, my
life as a son, my life as a
brother, my life as a husband,
my life as a friend.
And yet music is always the tool
that I think is going to
unlock these mysteries for me.
INTERVIEWER: Sure.
I guess for people such as
yourself, it provides a
certain sort of structure
by which to view life.
So it kind of makes sense that
the book would unfold by that.
You mentioned earlier that
neither you nor your father is
a particularly talented
singer, per se.
And yet you're a karaoke
fanatic.
So what does go into a good
karaoke performance, if it's
not the technical
singing ability?
ROB SHEFFIELD: It just comes
down to just enthusiasm and
passion and courage, if
courage is required.
Something that blows my mind,
it's kind of like when I was a
teenager in Boston, I was going
to punk rock shows.
There'd be the Saturday
afternoon hardcore matinee
shows, which were the all-ages
shows, with just a crummy
local band, douchebag
kids my age just
plugging in their guitars.
Not any more talented than I
was, but they were getting up
and doing it.
And I used to love to go to
those all-ages hardcore shows
and always totally get
my ass kicked.
But that was part of the fun
was that these guys, they
weren't waiting for anybody to
tell them they were good
enough to play music.
They just got up there
and did it.
And karaoke has that same kind
of punk rock spirit where, if
you're willing to get
up and do it,
that's all that's required.
You just have to put yourself
up there and be willing to
risk a certain amount
of ridicule.
INTERVIEWER: Was there stage
fright the first time you
tried this out?
ROB SHEFFIELD: Yeah,
terrifying.
I still remember the first time
so well because it was
something that I dreamed
of all my life.
have Everybody does the thing
in the bathroom mirror, with
the hair dryer as the guitar
and the hair brush as the
microphone.
But I never got any further than
the mirror in terms of
that fantasy.
I was out to dinner
with some friends.
And they're total
karaoke fiends.
And they were like, yeah,
we're going to sing.
And I was like, yeah,
I'll sit.
I'll enjoy.
I'll listen to my friends.
I'll clap.
I'll soak up the vibe.
And that'll be that.
And seeing them do it, but
also seeing just the way
everybody had so much fun with
it, kind of lured me in.
And I sang a song by ELO, this
unbelievably great rock
classics of the '70s, where
"Telephone Line," everybody
remembers that ELO song.
I was like, yeah, let's go
up-tempo on this one that
everybody can sing "Doo wop
dooby dooby wop." I forgot
that before you get to that
chorus, you go through some of
the most depressing, desolate,
lonely, desperate verses,
where they guy's on the phone.
He's like, hello.
How are you?
Have you been--
he's just talking to her
ringing phone because
answering machine's weren't
even invented yet.
So he's just talking to
the ringing phone.
And I was like, OK, if I can
just get to the chorus with
the "Doo wop dooby dooby wop,"
it's going to be OK.
And it was.
And I was obsessed instantly.
INTERVIEWER: I know you talk
some in the book, I believe,
about certain songs that have
been detached from their
meaning, like "One," U2's, for
example, which is not a love
song, per se, but people kind
of interpret it as such.
What sort of feedback have you
gotten from actual musicians
about how they feel
about people doing
karaoke for their tracks?
ROB SHEFFIELD: Something that
blows my mind is how much
actual musicians love karaoke.
It's really funny how much real
rock stars, who actually
have their own songs and their
own audiences and their own
concert halls--
I remember the first time I was
talking to Simon Le Bon of
Duran Duran, Nick Rhodes, two
of my all-time rock idols.
And I'd just written a book
name-checking them in the title.
And I was interviewing them
for "Rolling Stone."
And they said, well, what's
your next book about?
And I said, well, I have this
idea that I want to write
about karaoke.
And they were like,
oh, karaoke!
And Simon Le Bon told me that
the first time he ever sang
karaoke was in the
'80s in Malaysia.
And they'd never heard
of karaoke before.
And they saw it in
a karaoke bar.
And he got up and sang "Material
Girl," and Elton
John's manager just got up
there and started doing a
strip tease.
And the way he talked about it,
like he remembered-- and I
was like, dude.
You're an actual rock star.
You don't have to
sing "Material
Girl" to get an audience.
You've been singing your own
songs in front of your own
crowds for 30 years.
But he still remembers
that night.
And that kind of
blows my mind.
A friend of mine interviewed
Robert Plant for "Rolling
Stone." Robert Plant just had
the most amazing story about
doing karaoke in China, where
nobody recognized him, nobody
had heard of him.
And he was like, I'm going to
bring the house down, because
there was a karaoke contest
at the end of the night.
And he did Elvis, "It's
Now or Never."
And he said, but I
came in second.
I was beaten by a guy from
Taiwan doing Tony Orlando and
Dawn, "Tie a Yellow Ribbon
'Round the Old Oak Tree." And
Robert Plant was like, wait.
How did I get beaten by
this dude singing
"Tie a Yellow Ribbon"?
And I think that's what rock
stars love about karaoke is
that fantasy that, if they
didn't have the name and the
reputation and the myth to fall
back on, that they could
still start over from
scratch and just
earn it all over again.
And that karaoke sort of lets
them slum it in the trenches
with the rest of us.
So it's funny that actual
musicians, however they might
fear the way I butcher their
songs in the karaoke bar--
I wouldn't want them to hear
me do it-- but funny how
actual, actual rockers, there's
something in it that
responds to them.
INTERVIEWER: I assume
this was all done in
the pre-YouTube era.
ROB SHEFFIELD: Yes.
OK, the combination of karaoke
and video is absolutely crazy.
I was singing karaoke,
a couple months ago.
This is how I find out that
Vine was invented, a very
traumatic way to discover
that Vine was invented.
I was singing with a sort of
mixed crowd generationally.
There were some of us who were
born before 1990, who, for
lack of a better collective
noun, I
will call normal people.
And then there are people who
are after 1990, who are like--
and the next day, everybody
was emailing, like, yeah,
look, I put up this Vine
thing on Twitter.
And I was like, Vine.
I wonder what that is.
Oh, it's seven seconds of me
singing Britney Spears's
"Toxic" in a very toxic site--
And I was like, wow.
This exists now.
Great.
I was like, the karaoke
humiliation boundaries have
been expanded.
Thank you, Vine, for kicking
down that door.
INTERVIEWER: That touches on
an interesting aspect about
karaoke, the multi-generational
appeal.
I think you mention
this in the book.
But that is-- it's not an
exclusively American
experience, but it's a kind of
uniquely American experience,
in that I think you call
it maybe a democratic
environment, if I'm quoting
you correctly.
ROB SHEFFIELD: Yeah.
There's definitely nothing
quite like it in American
culture, the way America uses
karaoke, the way it brings
people from different age
groups, different tastes in
music, different cultural
backgrounds, different
personality types, all mixing it
up and performing for each
other and listening
to each other and
applauding each other.
The most mind-blowing thing of
karaoke for me is that people
go there to enjoy listening to
other people sing badly.
If you want to listen to
yourself sing badly, you can
sing in the shower
or in the car.
We all do that.
We sing to our plants, our
cats, like the mirror.
But you go to karaoke, and it's
almost like we go there
to make each other stars.
And you see ordinary people with
maybe even less talent
than yourself--
I've never had that
experience--
but where they're going up
there, and you cheer for them.
And just seeing strangers
cheering for each other and
high-fiving each other, that's
a really mind-blowing aspect
of karaoke for me.
INTERVIEWER: Well, I know you've
been a music critic
since you've been an editor
for "Stone" since '97.
ROB SHEFFIELD: Yeah, '97.
INTERVIEWER: And it seems like
engaging with music via
criticism and engaging it via
karaoke are almost two
entirely different things.
One's very solitary and very
critical, and the other's very
social and very celebratory.
Do you get that at all?
ROB SHEFFIELD: Yeah.
It's a weird kind of clash
between different parts of my
soul as a music fan.
Just because when you're a music
critic, you're kind of
kidding yourself that I have the
theory of how music works.
I figure out how this stuff
operates, how it functions in
our lives, what music
should be like.
There's all this kind of
arrogance of will to knowledge
that you can kid
yourself about.
Then you go to the karaoke room,
and you're like, wow, I
don't understand anything.
Music is so much weirder than
I could ever imagine.
I was singing with a bunch of
friends a couple weeks ago,
and somebody did a song that
I have hated, hated, hated,
hated, hated since the '90s.
Does anybody remember
the Verve Pipe?
OK.
They had a song.
OK, that song had not crossed my
mind in well over 10 years.
And this dude, who was another
one of those awesome
22-year-olds, he gets up,
and he starts doing "The
Freshmen" the Verve.
And I was like, OK.
This is really weirding
me out.
I never thought I was ever going
to hear this song again.
The song, it's about
20 minutes long.
There's a plot.
I can't figure out quite what
the plot is, but it involves
[SINGING]
oh, I am not responsible.
And I was like, wow, I
hated this song then.
I never expected to hear
it again in my life.
But this is kind of awesome.
I'm really enjoying this.
And of course, I was like, OK,
if we're going to the '90s
one-hit wonders, I'll see your
Verve Pipe, and I'll raise you
a Primitive Radio Gods.
But there's that thing of, you
think you have this idea of
how music works and what the
boundaries are and what the
confines are, and karaoke is a
place I always realize that
music is so much weirder than is
even comprehensible to me.
INTERVIEWER: Is there any song
you've run into that's
completely karaoke-proof,
instrumentals aside, of course.
But anything that can't be done
in a reasonable manner?
ROB SHEFFIELD: It's weird.
Different--
it depends so much on the
vibe of the crowd.
I used to go to this place
where they said, we
only have two rules.
No "Stairway to Heaven," and no
"American Pie." And they're
like, they're both great songs,
but they're too long,
and they're too sad.
Sometimes people, they feel like
doing a long, sad song,
like that damn Verve
Pipe song.
And yet, if somebody brings that
requisite enthusiasm and
passion to it, you can listen
to a song that you've hated
for years and think, like, OK,
I get what this person hears
of themselves in this song.
And I'm hearing, even
reluctantly, some of
myself in this song.
INTERVIEWER: It seems like as
a music critic, you have the
ability to kind of break songs
down in terms of their
technical, mechanical component
parts, like the
bigger chorus, bridge
at a certain place.
Do you find yourself doing
that in terms of karaoke
songs, saying that--
listening to this, and this
would the perfect template for
a karaoke jam?
ROB SHEFFIELD: Yeah.
It's wild how, just getting
into the sort of karaoke
mindset, but also having the
critical mindset to realize
how some people, when you
realize how they write songs
for their voice--
Neil Diamond is a
great example.
I grew up in America, so
I love Neil Diamond.
Always heard those songs.
My parents always had
them on the radio.
And I thought I knew those
songs, and I thought I
appreciated the Neil
Diamond cosmology.
And yet you sing them
in a karaoke bar,
and it's like, wow.
This guy, he really knows how
his voice works, what his
limitations are.
He has lots of breathing
spaces in his songs.
So I like them a lot.
He likes to sing one line and
then wait about 30 seconds.
You have [SINGING]
love on the rocks.
Ain't no big surprise.
And that man is pure
confidence,
pure superhuman bravado.
And you hope a little that's
going to rub off on you when
you sing him.
INTERVIEWER: So I know you
titled the book "Turn Around
Bright Eyes." It could have just
as easily been "Seeing My
Life" or any of the other
numerous chapters you have.
Why did you single out that
one particular song?
ROB SHEFFIELD: Well, "Total
Eclipse of the Heart" is one
of those karaoke things.
You're always going to hear
it in a karaoke bar.
It's like that and "Livin'
on a Prayer," "Don't Stop
Believin'." There are some
songs that you hear
them all the time.
Once, I went to karaoke with
a friend of mine who's a
wedding video guy.
And he was getting really
stressed out.
He was like, just hearing "Don't
Stop Believin'" and
"Livin' on a Prayer" all night,
he's like, this is like
being at work.
Because those songs are
just requisite.
For me, "Total Eclipse of the
Heart" is really personal
because that's the first song
that I sang as a karaoke duet
with my wife.
Which was just when
we first met.
It was 10 years ago.
I brought her to a party in
New York, in Chinatown.
A friend of mine had
a loft party.
In all candor, it was a fairly
druggy party, and it was kind
of a strange sort of vibe.
And of course, karaoke
was part of that.
They had a couple
karaoke hosts.
And I said to Ally, I was
like, let's do a duet.
And she was like, yeah.
And we picked out "Total
Eclipse of the Heart."
And she just instinctively did
the hard part, the [SINGING]
"Every now and then I get a
little--" But there's one part
of the song that has like 600
words, and it's really
complicated.
And there's one where it's
easy because it's just,
[SINGING]
"Turn around." And I was just
doing the [SINGING]
"Turn around" and
turning around.
And I was watching her.
And she doesn't know anybody
in this room.
These are my friends.
And I was like, wow, this
chick is fearless.
And I was like, wow.
I feel like just singing this
song with her, I feel like I'm
learning all this
stuff about her.
And so it's funny that that
song, I just associate with
that moment.
Because really, falling in love
with someone and karaoke,
they require the same kind of
courage, the same kind of
delusion, on some level.
What the downside could be, and
yet you're like, OK, I'll
take a chance on this anyway.
And so for me, getting obsessed
with karaoke around
the same time that I was
starting my relationship with
her, for me, that song, "Total
Eclipse of the Heart," they
were very, very woven in with
that sort of emotional change.
INTERVIEWER: Would you two begin
to practice karaoke at
home before going
out to karaoke?
ROB SHEFFIELD: No, I feel
like practicing karaoke
is kind of-- yeah.
It's kind of like--
like remember when Trivial
Pursuit was new?
And my parents had a friend that
they would play Trivial
Pursuit with that they would
to try to learn.
They would study the questions
so they could--
and I was like, that takes the
whole point out of it.
That makes it not
a game anymore.
Like they had a very uptight
couple friend who would quiz
each other on the yellows and
the browns, and they'd study
the cards so they
could remember.
I was like, that's not the way
the game is supposed to be--
and I feel like karaoke,
it's the same thing.
I feel like if you're actually
rehearsing--
although part of the thing is
that some people, what they
bring to it, they love
to rehearse.
It makes them better singers.
I don't do it that way.
But everybody brings their
own karaoke mojo to it.
INTERVIEWER: I know in the book,
you also mention you and
Ally's shared respect and
admiration for the music
critic Greil Marcus, who
wrote many, many books.
Have you seen him karaoke?
Does he have a go-to karaoke
jam, do you think?
ROB SHEFFIELD: He told me
he has never karaoked.
This is Greil Marcus, one of
my all-time writer heroes.
So he's written about music.
And he actually had a band of
other authors that he played
in, the Rock Bottom Remainders
with Dave Barry and Stephen
King and Dave Marsh, and a
bunch of other flat-out
no-talents who were just writers
who enjoyed having
this garage band together.
And he said, I could
even do that.
But the idea of karaokeing,
he was just like, no way.
Never.
Not in this life.
But it's funny that for music
critics and for those of us
who adopt a kind of--
who aspire to a certain studious
expertise about
music, it's weird how much of
that you have to let go of in
the karaoke room because all
your theories that you bring
in can be completely invalidated
by one dude
singing the Verve Pipe.
It's really great.
INTERVIEWER: I like Greil
Marcus and his book,
"Invisible Republic." He
positioned this Bob Dylan
song, "I'm Not There," as a
canonical Bob Dylan track,
which maybe, when he
wrote that book,
1,000 people have heard.
Do you have a similar sort
of holy grail of
karaoke that you--
ROB SHEFFIELD: You know, there
are some songs that I like to
sing at karaoke because I kind
of think that these are songs
the world has forgotten, that
maybe one karaoke bar at a
time, we could sort
of revive them.
Because there's definitely the
phenomenon of songs that are
hits, then they disappear, and
then they kind of come back in
public consciousness, only
because of karaoke.
"Total Eclipse of the Heart"
is a good example.
That's one that karaoke
made that song.
That's a song that was a hit.
Then the radio was not
playing it anymore.
But because people love to
sing in karaoke bars.
Another great example is
Ginuwine, "Pony," which was a
huge summer hit,
summer of '96.
I was living in the
South back then.
You heard that song
everywhere.
The most filthy song, the most
perfect song, and that's a
song that has come back, and
it's become famous again
strictly because people
love to karaoke it.
And it brings out something
super bold in
people, super brazen.
And so there are some songs that
I kind of always think,
maybe karaoke could perform
the same sort of
miracle for this song.
Like Frankie Goes to Hollywood,
OK, they had a
sensitive love ballad called
"The Power of Love." It was
their third hit.
Oh my god, I can't believe
you remember that song.
Nobody know that song.
I'm kind of shocked.
Everybody remembers
Frankie say relax.
"Relax" is a great song.
Everybody can probably
sing that one.
That's a great karaoke song.
"Two Tribes," which was their
second hit, which was their
angry, serious, political
song.
And then they had their third
with "The Power of Love,"
which is their sensitive
ballad.
And I adore that song.
But you know, it's
like, [SINGING]
"The power of love, a force
from above, a skyscraping
dove." It's really sort of
wiggity wack, as the late,
great Kriss Kross would say.
And I saw that song in a karaoke
book once, and I
almost had this feeling of--
I was spiritually obligated
to sing it.
I was like, it's possible that
this song has been in this
karaoke book for years, and
not a single person
has ever sung it.
I just wanted it on the book,
somewhere in the karaoke
database, somewhere
that somebody,
somewhere sang this song.
And it was almost like I felt
an urgent need to do it.
And I warned my friends
before I did it.
I was like, you might not
like this one so much.
And I was actually right.
A lot of people were casually
taking their bathroom breaks
during that song.
But there are always
obscurities, and sometimes you
discover them in the karaoke
bar, and you try to share them
in the karaoke bar.
That's part of what it's for.
INTERVIEWER: Do each kind of
karaoke bars have their own
nuance in terms of catalog
and playlists that
you can look for?
ROB SHEFFIELD: Yeah.
Every one of them
is different.
Some of them are--
it's really funny.
Every karaoke bar has
its own vibe.
Some of them are super-sleazy.
They're dark.
They're almost like in old
movies, where you see the
opium dens.
It's like that kind of thing.
Like people come there because
they need a fix of the singing
experience, and nobody wants
to be recognized.
And there are other places that
are bright and festive.
And there are some places that
are family friendly.
are vaguely sinister.
And the song books are
always different.
There's this one place that I
love to go to in New York, in
Koreatown, called Music Story,
that has all these Yngwie
Malmsteen songs in the book,
Yngwie Malmsteen, the Swedish
death metal guitarist.
I was like, I didn't know his
songs even had words.
Nobody is a Malmsteen fan
because they like to sing
those songs.
But I was like, this is kind of
amazing that they're in the
karaoke book, which
means somebody,
somewhere is singing them.
And that's part of the
beautiful thing.
The same place that has 17
different songs in the book by
the Christian metal
band Stryper.
And I was like, wow.
I thought I probably knew more
about Stryper than a lot of my
friends, but I could not name
17 different Stryper songs.
That's part of the magic
of every place we were.
INTERVIEWER: A Rhino comp
of undiscovered
karaoke cuts or something.
But in the book, you kind of lay
out a timeline of karaoke.
And I was surprised you didn't
mention the Scarlett
Johansson, Bill Murray scene
within "Lost in Translation."
But I think you circle back to
it, and listed as kind of the
perfect karaoke tune,
or a very ideal one.
Can you discuss that at all?
ROB SHEFFIELD: Yeah, it's
[INAUDIBLE] because karaoke,
it's funny that it didn't take
long in the noughties for
movies to start realizing that
if you put a karaoke scene in
a movie, it's super effective
and super easy.
It requires no imagination.
You just have characters just--
and this is their
awkward, ungainly
way of bonding.
And that you can put it in any
kind of move, a rom-com or a
crime thriller or
a goofy comedy.
And the karaoke scene is
always going to work.
There's this great one.
Really, this one always--
I was watching this recently
because "Breaking Bad" just
started a new season.
And there's that great
karaoke scene on
"Breaking Bad" where--
OK, total non-spoilerish,
how do I put this?
There was a character who's no
longer alive, and who had
vaguely criminal associations.
And the cops going through
his stuff, they're like,
wow, look at this.
They find this karaoke video
he made in a karaoke bar,
where he's singing Major Tom
coming home, which is one of
my karaoke.
You know, [SINGING]
four, three, two, one,
earth below.
And you see this video
of this guy.
And it's just heartbreaking.
And you see him, and it's like
you're seeing him at his most
vulnerable and intimate, just
when he's singing this great,
old cheesy New Wave song from
the '80s in the karaoke bar.
And it's amazing the way the
karaoke story that movies and
TV shows keep finding
a way to tell--
at this point, there's
going to be karaoke
scenes in all movies.
INTERVIEWER: Wasn't there one
in "Blue Velvet," or am I
remembering that correctly?
ROB SHEFFIELD: I guess "Blue
Velvet," because it's sort of
pre-karaoke, so he's performing
in the lounge.
INTERVIEWER: Maybe I was
thinking of "My Own Private
Idaho."
ROB SHEFFIELD: The first time
I saw a karaoke scene in a
movie was "The Crying Game" in
'92, where the guy goes to the
karaoke bar.
I saw that in rural Virginia
in the spring of '91.
And it really blew me away.
And I was like, wow.
That looks like fun.
It's set in London.
And there's a karaoke bar, where
he's like, if you want
to find this person, she's
always at this bar at this
time, and she always things
the same song, "The Crying
Game." And movies like that
started to circulate before
actual karaoke establishments
did.
So I think a big watershed one
was in '97, where there was
the Julia Roberts movie, "My
Best Friend's Wedding," where
karaoke plays a huge
role in that movie.
And this is '97.
Karaoke is still pretty rare in
most parts of the country
at this point.
But that movie was
in multiplexes
all over the country.
And everybody sees that movie.
And all our moms saw that movie
and thought, holy cow,
that looks like fun.
So I karaoke with my mom now,
down in her little senior
village in Florida.
And everybody loves karaoke
as soon as they
find out about it.
INTERVIEWER: I know there was
this one part in your book
where you mention that new music
is not necessarily being
made for you, per se, as
a demographic audience.
But it seems like karaoke is
the one place where people,
those of us who were born before
1990 can still go and
supplement that rave or the
hardcore concert experience.
ROB SHEFFIELD: Yeah.
It's amazing how karaoke,
because of its nature, it's
not bound to generational ties,
where it's like, oh, you
were born at this time, so you
have to listen to this.
And of course, the way that
music technology is changing
so much, those boundaries are
less confining than ever.
Basically anybody can listen
to anything now, which it's
wild to think of how it used
to be and think you had to
actually have a physical
copy of the record.
You had to go to the ends
of the earth to find it.
I remember the first time
I had a copy of Dusty
Springfield's "Dusty in
Memphis" in my hands.
And I couldn't believe that I
found this record that my
friends and I had all been
searching for for years.
Now it's like something you just
hear in Starbucks, and
you don't even think about it.
My nieces and nephews, who are
little kids, they're really
into karaoke because it's on
their little karaoke video
game console.
And it's funny.
It's kind of traumatic for my
sisters because my nieces and
nephews, who are all toddlers,
little kids, they love doing
these songs that my sisters
thought that maybe they'd
heard the last of.
Like my nieces and nephews, they
love to do "Copa Cabana."
Remember that one?
They actually have this dance
routine that they
choreographed, where one of them
is Lola, and one of them
is Tony, and one of
them is Rico.
Rico, he wore a diamond.
And they act out the whole
plot of the song.
And my sister, I vividly--
I love the image of my
sister watching this.
And she's like, I kind of
thought that this already came
and went for me.
She's like, I did not envision
an adulthood where I was
hearing this song
10 times a day.
And they love to do "Dust
in the Wind" and "Sister
Christian" and all these
other songs that my
sister can't stand.
But that's part of how karaoke
is, just part of how
technology general is just
opening music up to people.
INTERVIEWER: Music has changed
drastically in these past 10
years, just in terms of
the technology side.
Has there been any transition
in karaoke, similar?
ROB SHEFFIELD: Well, because
karaoke is so mobile now, I
actually did--
my wife was out of
town last year.
And actually, we were like, hey,
this would probably work.
I actually brought the laptop to
the karaoke bar, and we did
Skype-aoke.
And it was like, that
really worked.
It was not necessarily
my proudest moment.
And I'm sure for people walking
by and looking, they
were like, OK.
This dude has a really
sad life.
He's in the karaoke room, by
himself, singing to a screen.
But that was fun.
And just like a friend of mine
in New York found this Korean
place in the east 30s
that has spa-raoke.
Where she had a spa-raoke
birthday party where it's a
spa where they have
a karaoke machine.
And the birthday girl's getting
a pedicure while she's
singing Stevie Nicks.
And it's like her two favorite
things in the
world, spa and karaoke.
Now they can be combined.
The future is completely
unbounded.
Like the idea that you can get
your nails did and sing your
song at the same time is
just mind-blowing.
INTERVIEWER: Absolutely.
I have a couple more questions,
but I was wondering
if anyone in the audience had
anything they'd like to ask
Rob at this point.
There's a microphone right
there, by the way.
AUDIENCE: So my question is, I
know that you spent time in
Charlottesville, based on--
ROB SHEFFIELD: Yeah.
You too?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, UVA.
ROB SHEFFIELD: All right.
All right.
Wow.
OK.
All right.
I spent the whole '90s
in Charlottesville.
Love that place.
AUDIENCE: So my question for
that is, and I haven't been
able to read this book, so you
might cover it yet, but did
you notice a difference singing
karaoke, say, in
Manhattan versus
Charlottesville, Virginia?
And what were the differences
there?
ROB SHEFFIELD: It's
wild because
it's funny that karaoke--
it's so different from place to
place that the boundaries--
when I go back to
Charlottesville, and I sing karaoke--
I still go back there all the
time, still have lots of
friends and family there.
And it's wild that you hear a
lot more country songs there.
But there's different--
because every place has
its different vibe.
The first time I heard that
country song, "Before He
Cheats," remember that?
That was a Carrie Underwood
hit a few years ago.
The first time I heard that
was in a karaoke bar.
And it was in Charlottesville.
And it was just someone that I
didn't know just getting up to
the mic and singing this super
scary song about how she's
going to destroy this guy's
car and destroy his life.
And it actually mentions
karaoke.
Like, that girl, she's probably
singing some white
trash version of
Shania karaoke.
And it's like, wow.
And I was like, hearing this
song in a karaoke bar,
absolute best first
way to hear it.
And I will always love that
song because of my first
experience with it.
So it's a weird thing, going and
singing karaoke all over
the country.
It's funny how every place has
its different rituals, its
different etiquette and
its different code.
And it's funny how it's
different every place.
That's part of the fascination
for me.
INTERVIEWER: Have you ever heard
a song at a karaoke bar
that you really liked, then
heard the original version and
been like, this is trash?
ROB SHEFFIELD: Boy,
all the time.
It's funny, that happens to my
wife all the time because she
doesn't listen to a lot
of current top 40 pop.
So she will hear me destroy
songs in the karaoke bar long
before she hears the original.
And I still remember a couple
years ago, when the singer
Ke$ha, Ke$ha, was on the
American Music Awards, doing
her hit "We R Who We R."
And Ally was listening.
And she was like, wow, that's
the first time I'm hearing
actually Ke$ha sing this song.
And she's like, wow.
She sounds just like you do when
you're drunk at 2:00 in
the morning.
I was like, that's why it's
the perfect karaoke song.
And it's funny how, yeah,
sometimes that's the main
experience with the song.
AUDIENCE: I haven't been in a
karaoke bar in a really long
time, and I have very
limited experience.
ROB SHEFFIELD: Time
to change that.
AUDIENCE: I know, I now.
So back whenever that was, hip
hop, rap, basically was not
available in a karaoke.
It wasn't as big, obviously,
culturally as it is now.
But it's a huge part of music.
It's a huge part of pop music.
So has that changed?
Is it changing?
Do you find rap options
in karaoke bars more
than you used to?
It seems like as far as if
karaoke is like a fantasy for
people, that there's
a lot of fantasy in
rap music in lyrics.
It would make a lot of sense.
But it's not singing,
necessarily.
ROB SHEFFIELD: Yeah.
But it's vocalizing and
performing, and there's often
different singing involved.
Also, it's really hard if
you don't have actual
hip-hop-worthy mic skills.
And so I will often begin
a lot of hip hop songs.
And then I'll be like, wow.
This is hard.
I need to lie down with a
cold towel over my head.
I will try like "Mo Money Mo
Problems." And I was like, OK,
the Mase verse I can handle.
The Puffy verse is a little
complicated for me.
The Biggie verse, I am
not even worthy.
I'm not even going to
step to that one.
But it's funny because with the
hip hop and the hip hop
aesthetic keeps changing pop
music, and pop music keeps
responding to that.
That's part of--
my karaoke fantasy for 2013, I
can't wait until this song
arrives at the bar, is--
well, all the songs from the
new Kanye West album,
"Yeezus," especially the last
song, "Bound To," which is one
that samples Brenda Lee, singing
like "uh-huh, honey."
And I cannot wait until that
song comes to the karaoke bar.
In fact, I was out with a bunch
of friends of mine last
week, and we were doing all
these other Kanye West songs
in the book, just trying to do
that song over the different--
so we did "Runaway," but we kept
doing the "uh-huh, honey"
all the way through it.
It's funny because that "uh-huh,
honey," that's from a
song that I learned as a kid
because my parents had their
records from the '50s, and they
had these '50s rock and
roll records.
And one of the songs I loved
was Brenda Lee, "Sweet
Nothin's," from the '50s.
And just the way she would
begin that song saying
"uh-huh, honey," and I just
thought that was the filthiest
thing I'd ever heard.
I couldn't believe my parents
had his record.
I was like, how was
this allowed?
And now I hear that sound all
the time of her saying that in
that Kanye West song.
And that somehow, he decided to
just loop that Brenda Lee
"uh-huh, honey" all the way
through the song, a truly
filthy song.
And it's mind-blowing for me,
and it's just evidence of how
music keeps expanding, keep
getting weirder, and keeps
crossing those boundaries.
It's really amazing.
AUDIENCE: So you are finding
it out there.
I can go to a karaoke bar now
and find hip hop as an option.
ROB SHEFFIELD: Yeah.
More and more--
and it's funny because some
hip hop songs are more
karaoke-friendly than others.
And it's funny because of
the skill sets required.
I think people in general, just
watching people do hip
hop songs in karaoke bars,
they tend to kind of
overestimate their mic skills.
Like you realize, there's a
reason Jay-Z is Jay-Z, and
you're not Jay-Z, because
you try to do--
Like I once tried to do H to
the Izzo, V to the Izzay.
And I was like, wow.
The chorus I can handle.
But I was like, I felt like
I owed Jay-Z an apology.
I was like, I didn't mean
to do this to your song.
If I ever meet you, I will have
to apologize for that.
AUDIENCE: But do you feel the
same way if you don't hit a
note from a singer?
ROB SHEFFIELD: Yeah,
the same way.
I'm OK with the fact that
I'm not going to do
justice to the song.
I can't aspire to do justice
to the song.
All I can do is just shine my
own badly performed version of
it, just my way of saying thank
you to the song and to
the artist.
INTERVIEWER: In short, do you
think Chief Keef will be more
popular with karaoke bars than
Kendrick Lamar in five years?
ROB SHEFFIELD: Yeah.
Well, part of it is that--
like Nicki Minaj, who has lots
of songs that are impossible
to do with karaoke.
But she also has "Beez in the
Trap," which I really think
she designed to be karaokeable,
because that's a
song that if you want to do a
Nicki Minaj song, but you
don't have Nicki Minaj skills,
that one is really slowed down
to the point where I really
think she was like, OK, I have
to do something for the really
drunk douchebags who decide
they're going to try this
at 2:00 in the morning.
And it's actually
really great.
I always do the 2 Chainz part
because my wife is kind of
obsessed with 2 Chainz.
INTERVIEWER: OK.
Well, Rob, thanks for coming
out here, man.
ROB SHEFFIELD: Thank
you for coming.
Oh my god, thank you everybody.
Thank you.